Tesla CEO Elon Musk startled Wall Street
by saying he may be preparing to take
his struggling electric carmaker
private the announcement sent the
company's stock price soaring and led
the Nasdaq to stop trading Tesla shares
for a short time Sony Tecopa is at a
Manhattan Tesla dealership with the
factors behind potentially the largest
buyout in US history Tony good morning
good morning that stock price soared
because musk is suggesting a buyout
price considerably higher than what the
stock is currently trading at now no
decision has been made and ultimately
it'll be up to shareholders but take a
look at these cars behind me since musk
started selling them as a public company
in 2010 he has never turned an annual
profit
this latest declaration is a sign of
just how badly he'd like to fix that
high-profile announcements are nothing
new for Elon Musk unlike any truck that
you've ever driven and after Wall
Street's opening on Tuesday musk
delivered another stunner the
unconventional CEO tweeted he was
considering taking Tesla private at 420
dollars a share musk elaborated in a
letter to employees saying he'd like to
free Tesla from the quote distraction
that comes from being a publicly traded
company including swings in stock price
quarterly earnings pressure and people
incentivized to attack the company gen
vh nur is a senior writer for Fortune
magazine he wants the freedom to take
risks and not be punished in the market
for it taking it private would allow him
to do that much of Tesla's trouble with
investors has revolved around the
company's model three sedan which only
recently began shipping after months of
delays I'm feeling really good about
where things are headed musk addressed
Tesla's critics when he sat down with
Gayle King in April this was very
frequently been why people have
underestimated Tesla because they would
look at Tesla's what has done in the
past and use that as proxy for what we
were able to do in the future
if Elon Musk is facing scrutiny and
pressure when he's operating out in
public what confidence should anyone
have that he can do a better job in a
private company well you have to
in Elon Musk the genius you know this
guy oh you must believe he's got many
private companies he's done it before
you know he's got SpaceX which may be
the first company that takes people to
Mars this is something that people just
believe in it in him
to innovate and to grow the company you
gotta believe now much says that
shareholders will have a choice between
sticking in this deal or exiting if they
want to stick in it is a big potential
deal Dell went private in 2013 that was
one of the biggest buyouts on record
this proposed Tesla deal would be more
than three times as large as much as
eighty two billion dollars a lot of gas
in the tank hill a lot a lot of gas a
lot of money Elon Musk always keeps it
interesting thank you very much Tony to
Coco